Hi. Today,
we're going to show you how
to connect GitHub Copilot to an
RStudio project on Posit Cloud.
The first thing to do is
create a new RStudio project.
And when the
project is loading,
we can go ahead and give
it a name. Maybe AI Coding Assistant.
And then as soon as
the project loads,
we're gonna go ahead and
authenticate through GitHub.
To do that, you're gonna
click Tools on the navigation bar,
then Global Options,
scroll down to Copilot,
and you can enable
GitHub Copilot.
First, you're going to install
some packages in the IDE.
Once this is ready,
you're going to be able
to sign in now to GitHub.
So if you click on this button,
it's going to give you a
verification code. You can copy
that. And take it
to a GitHub link.
Paste in the verification
code. Click continue.
Authorize GitHub Copilot.
Now you're done here.
You can close this tab
and come back into the IDE.
This will update and it'll show
you that you are now logged in
and ready to use Copilot.
So we can open up a new
script to show it off.
Maybe I'll rename that
eda.R.
And we can start passing
in, you know, human language text.
Right? Make a function
that's going to calculate
the area of a room.
You can click enter,
and you're gonna see
the recommendation from GitHub Copilot.
You can click tab to
accept the recommendation,
and you can run it,
and now you have a
function `area()` in your environment.
You can also ask it
to say, you know,
I have a room of
a certain size,
find out the area of the floor,
and it's going to know that
it's going to take the formula
that I just defined,
and be able to run this and
find out that the area is in
fact eighty for my size room.
I can also use, like,
an auto complete.
So let's load in ggplot2.
And if I start
typing the function `ggplot()` here,
you're going to see that it's
gonna start filling it in for
me with some, you
know, recommendations.
Okay.
Let's just go ahead and accept this
and see what it comes up with.
You know, a pretty
basic first ggplot.
But then you can work with
it again with human language and
say things like, well,
maybe I wanna change the
color of the data points.
It would do that
based on the variable class.
We can accept this and run it.
And now we've got, you know,
a slightly improved graphic,
and you can keep iterating on
this using Copilot to help you
out make new things and
hopefully make them faster.